do you have a hard time booking acting
work no because I'm not trying to when I
was yes very much so oh yeah you know
like i said i'm not i Mun castable I'm
not you look at me and you get a very
clear idea of what I should be doing and
then I go and ruin it by opening my
mouth and I start talking and it's not
it doesn't it doesn't fit and and I get
it I'm not I'm not an easy I'm sure my
agents and managers god bless him you
guys are awesome but I mean I can't be
an easy person to represent as an actor
because i have really eclectic tastes
that do not match what I look like and
that's part of the game you know like I
was saying before it's like you have to
know where you fit in and it's weird for
me because I know what I look like but I
don't know what to make an accent and I
don't smoke weed and I don't know an
African accent I know I'm super dark but
I've never been to Africa I don't know
how that works I'm a guy who grew up
watching woody allen movies you know and
that's the thing I you know sit me at a
dinner table with intelligent folk great
meal and bowel wine and we can talk
philosophy all night that's great like
I'm that guy no one's looking for that
guy to look like me I'm sayin like
that's not the guy I don't it's not no
one's so so I started creating I would
just I would just put myself in that
position because that's what's true to
me despite what I
look like was that something that came
you know house people can't always see
how others see them they just know
themselves they know that what they like
right would do you remember when people
started saying well I don't really see
you in this light or you should be more
this oh it was immediate and take folks
long ago what the hell's wrong with you
I was spoiled in my in my acting classes
because my acting coach gave me like
everything I mean I was doing scenes
from carnal knowledge and and midnight
cowboy and the Godfather so the material
was stellar you know what I mean and
that's what I trained on in the acting
class so when I got out and I would
audition you know for like bug number
four it wasn't the same caliber as
Midnight Cowboy I know it wasn't quite
the same and there were there were just
nuances and things that I had learned
especially after working with Steven
Bochco and and his incredible writing
staff I was I was I was lucky I was very
fortunate as a young tyke because I got
to work with incredibly talented writers
and incredibly talented directors and
people who like were at the top of their
game and for whatever reason said okay
you come play with us and that's a rare
to rare fine it's a rare thing so as I
got older and I got past that it became
increasingly harder to find that again
because you know I
I don't know I just I I come from a
different place myself and it doesn't
always sync up with how I look and so
that made the whole auditioning process
a little bit difficult not just for me
but for my representatives to I felt bad
for him
you